aujourd'hui le mot cap de
bourbach-le-haut aujourd'hui découvrir
la paix à la victoire la paix à
l'allocation personnalisée d'autonomie
grâce à même pouvoir comprendre si vous
aussi découvrir ce qu'est l'allocation
personnalisée autonomie venez avec moi
[Musique]
la paix est une allocation personnalisée
d'autonomie cette aide financière est
destinée aux hasan âgé de plus de 60 ans
en perte d'autonomie soit disposition du
département c'est à bénéficier des
services nécessaires et
d'accomplissement des actes essentiels
de la vie ou d'aller l'entente
bonjour mesdames rue mardi alors madame
et demain qu'on suppose de la paix à
la paix ainsi très bonne chose pour les
personnes âgées et qui permettent aux
personnes de rester chez haute en ayant
une aide à domicile et d'une pièce le
popu deux autres de faire les courses le
dimanche administratif tout ce que je
peux plus faire seul et fait combien de
temps que maman et bénéficier de la psf
et cinq ans avait 5 ans et justement
après qu il ait pas là où il a reçu
auparavant de téléalarme ces petits
boîtiers
tpm et de que la personne âgée
ponctuelles quand on aime juste en cas
d'échec elle peut signaler compris de
sioux laisser tomber ça déclenche et ça
aussi c'est financé dans le cadre de la
peur oui ce dispositif quotas il ya pas
au tableau des partenaires de notre vie
de tous les jours à tous les deux mais
pour moi et permet à moins d'être auprès
d'elle ce qu'il faut aussi savoir c'est
que au delà de cette aide physique la
paix à c'est aussi une aide pour
financer tout ce qui est matériel pour
l'incontinence aider pour faire les
petits travaux d'amélioration de la
salle de bain plein de choses comme ça
il a de ce dispositif aussi pour
améliorer le maintien à domicile et le
quotidien de bénéficier à plein
merci beaucoup madame grille
depuis 2002 département se charge de
délivrer la paix à cette aide financière
de bénéficier de nombreux anonymes et
faites par des personnes qui souhaitent
rester à leur domicile mais aussi pour
celles qui sont en établissement les
manuels dans quel but a été créée la
paix a alors la paix à l'allocation
personnalisée d'autonomie a été créée
pour favoriser le bien vieillir à
domicile ou en établissement et du coup
c'est pour venir en aide à nos gramounes
pour pour lutter contre leur dépendance
quel public peut bénéficier de ce
dispositif alors c'est les personnes
âgées de 60 ans et plus qui sont en
perte d'autonomie donc qu'ils n'arrivent
plus à s'occuper de leur maison de faire
à manger du lac de se lever et qui
nécessite une surveillance régulière
alors il ya deux types d'appels on a la
paix à à domicile donc ça c'est pour
favoriser le maintien à domicile de chez
eux exactement et il ya aussi la paix à
en établissement donc ça aide à couvrir
une partie de la dépendance sur le
montant de la prestation qu'elle soit
une démarche à suivre pour pouvoir
bénéficier on peut aller sur le site
internet et prendre le formulaire de du
cfa
passé dans les départements dans les
services des actions de santé ou encore
aller au ccas aider éventuellement par
les prestataires
grâce à la paix à le quotidien de nos
gramounes devient plus facile la visite
d'auxiliaire de vie d'infirmières audio
personnes de la famille permet de lutter
contre les allemands mais aussi de
pouvoir garder leurs habitudes
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur la peine n'hésitez
pas vous avez toutes les coordonnées qui
s'affiche à votre écran le département
des générations c'est fini si vous
souhaitez vous voir cet épisode un cycle
et d'épisodes précédents rendez vous sur
nos sites et nourriture sociaux quant à
moi je vous retrouve très vite pas un
nouvel épisode à bientôt
la semaine prochaine je vous amène à la
cellule insertion de saint paul où nous
rencontrerons haifa qui a bénéficié du
nouveau pack jeune citoyen un joli coup
de pouce du département pour la
réinsertion des jeunes au niveau social
et professionnel
[Musique]